[Musique]
bonjour à vous deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin sur rtl france
je vais commencer par vous jean guy
bricout ce week-end anne hidalgo a donc
officialisé sa candidature pour
l'élection présidentielle
aaron elle doit encore être validé par
les militants du parti socialiste est ce
que c'est la bonne candidate selon vous
écouter on a tous est vrai en othe
modèle en politique un mot c'est bernard
cazeneuve autant vous le dire tout de
suite mais malgré tout je crois que
hindalco effectivement c'est
certainement une bonne candidate une
candidate qui a les capacités d'abord de
rassembler rassembler le parti de
rassembler la gauche qui a aussi je
pense une bonne capacité week-end
certaines expériences aussi la vie
politique des enjeux politiques des
combats politiques qui sait s'entourer
voilà c'est oui pour moi c'est une bonne
candidate est évidemment je soutiendrai
la personne qui sera désignée dans mon
parti
et puis ça que je vous dise y sera le
plus à même de rassembler la gauche je
gebert collard il ya eu aussi ce
week-end marqué par le premier grand
discours de marine le pen la chef lieu
du rassemblement national qui était à
fréjus elle a dévoilé son slogan liberté
liberté chérie un clin d'oeil à la
marseillaise je serai présidente de la
défense des libertés donc at elle dit
hier pourquoi choisir cet axe de
campagne selon vous c'est un choix de
civilisation
remercier et puis pour les lieux aussi
quand même ne l'oublions pas oui c'est
un choix de civilisation c'est si c'est
la volonté de rappeler que l'égalité et
la fraternité
ne peuvent pas exister s'il n'y a pas la
liberté
l'égalité la fraternité découle de la
liberté or depuis des années et des
années on pourrait même remonter jusqu'à
la phrase historique de pompidou qui
avait dit arrêtez d'emmerder les
français on a des attaches
technocratique bureaucratique tatillonne
[Musique]
d'une société qui est de plus en plus
une société de surveillance qui portent
atteinte aux structures au au corps
structurelle de nos libertés et on a
laissé faire on s'est laissé faire et il
est grand temps de réagir je tiens à
rappeler quand même que au coeur de son
discours marine le pen a placé le
référendum il serait grand temps
qu'aujourd'hui
maintenant qu'on a les techniques les
moyens qu'on redonne la parole ce peuple
au nom duquel tout est censé être
décidées y compris les décisions de
justice on a un peuple moderne qui est
absent de la démocratie il faudrait lire
et intégrée on a des institutions qui
sont
monarchique on peut en prendre des
exemples multiples 1 le conseil
constitutionnel désigné que par du
personnel politique de haut niveau le
csa désigné que par du personnel
politique il faut en finir avec ça il
faut que le peuple reprenne les moyens
de désigner celles et ceux qui
contrôlent les contrôleurs donc c'est un
vrai combat de civilisation oui c'est un
c'est un beau combat parce que c'est une
prise à bras le corps des problèmes
physiques juridique métaphysique de ce
siècle qui n'a pas su malheureusement
s'adapter à la part les dégâts femme qui
règne en maître kiki qui constitue une
puissance économique colossal à rentrer
dans
l'expression et je trouve que oui
puisque je termine là dessus après je
laisse la parole à tout le monde je
crois que il faut qu'on soit capable de
voir les problèmes qui nous assaillent
ne peut pas non pas on ne peut pas
laisser la liberté d'expression entre
les mains de superstructure économiques
privés puissante qui font ce qu'elles
peuvent un commentaire à cela monsieur
bricout
[Musique]
le parti socialiste la gauche est
attaché évidemment liberté
pour revenir sur notre candidate
évidemment
capacité des côtes de partage moi je
suis ça me paraît ça me parait des
orientations qui sont qui sont cruciales
c'est aussi elle s'appuie sur basso sur
notre programme qui me paraît moins
équilibré et qui permet justement un
rassemblement en prenant compte des les
grands enjeux les grands enjeux de
demain les enjeux écologiques avec une
vision humaniste une une transition
écologique qui sera nécessaire mais qui
cache des spurs se fera sans fracture
sociale sans fracture sans facteur
économique ce que j'ai peut-être encore
plus envie parce que moi je suis issu
d'un territoire rural il peut y avoir un
clivage entre la candidate et puis les
territoires quelque part mais la maire
jean louis bricout je suis désolé je
vous coupe la parole mais anne hidalgo
peut-être justement gommer cette image
parisienne elle a choisi rouen c'est pas
anodin voyez ce qu'on avait dit marine
le pen à l'époque où le couvre feu
devait être imposée à 18 heures en
france à cause de la crise sanitaire
est elle déjà sorti de paris 18h c'est
trop tôt pour tout le monde pas
seulement à paris fermé entre 18 et 20
heures c'est jeter encore une fois des
milliers des dizaines de milliers voire
des centaines de milliers
d'entrepreneurs dans une situation qui
est intenable alors voilà cette année
d'agropur gommer cette image parisienne
quand même qui lui colle à la peau
oui parce que je pense à eux écoutent
sait s'entourer on l'a vu elle sait
s'entourer eux elle s'entoure déjà
beaucoup d des maires des grandes villes
je crois que maintenant il faut qu'elles
qu'elles fassent aussi voilà qu'elle est
une du vert vers les élus eux plus
ruraux du nord mali qui est profonde
pour que voilà que l'ailé politique
quelle qu'elle veut mener s'adapte
complètement en automne notre réalité si
je prends par exemple
[Musique]
le secteur de l'automobile on n'a pas
une approche une à une relation avec
l'automobile qui est complètement
différente dans la réalité à paris alors
évidemment ça peut choquer ça peut
arriver mais voilà il faut trouver les
méthodes pour pour s'adapter
apporter des réponses et cette réalité
je crois que la ruralité a besoin d'être
d'être comprise mais ses capacités elle
et les élus et on est là pour ça pour
pour l'aider justement à apprendre des
dispositions qui s'adapte bien qu'ils
sont bien spécialité parce que voilà il
pas les choses tout à fait de la même
façon effectivement avec eux l'image
l'image parisienne qu'elle peut donner
je crois que et une écoute par la
différence attaques contre attaque anne
hidalgo a déclaré le 2 juin dernier que
marine le pen n'était pas républicaine
ont regardé
marine le pen ne défend pas les valeurs
de la république
elle n'est pas avec les idées qui sont
les siennes dans une capacité de
rassembler les français pour bien
présider il faut rassembler il faut
parler à tous les français allez un
commentaire gilbert collard a pas on va
regarder l'eau sondage qui va apparaître
à l'écran
non il ya pas de commentaires à faire
cela c'est la tarte à la crème de la
lada de la politique il faut que
commandent un ami d'alco peut-elle
encore en être là quoi marine le pen ne
défend pas les valeurs de la république
alors que nous sommes dans le débat
politique depuis des années des années
que nous avons au coeur de notre
programme l'amour de la patrie donc
l'amour de la république je pense pas
qu'elle pourra faire une belle campagne
en essayant de se présenter comme la
prêtresse des valeurs républicaines vous
savez moi je n'ai pas d'attentes faire
contre la personne parce que je déteste
cela je respecte toutes les idées je
crois qu on est en république et que
chaque parti qui concourent appartient
dans la république et que l'exclusion
l'ostracisme le mépris la méchanceté
voir n'est pas une manière d'incarner
notre devise un bon maintenant madame
hidalgo
jamais sorti de paris
abbas effet une insulte ça c'est un
constat géographique à vous me direz que
si elle veut sortir à 30 km heure il
faudra du temps mais ça c'est son
affaire c'est sa décision oui elle et
elle et elle est très parisienne mais
bon j'en ferais pas forcément un grief
ce que je dis est ce que je pourrais
faire c'est que j'ai pas envie que la
france ressemble à ce qui paraît
aujourd'hui voilà bombe et ça c'est une
opinion qui qui et comment pourrais je
dire de l'ordre du constat géographique
et urbain moi je considère que la ville
de paris a été très mal gérée qu'elle
est dans l'insécurité qu'elle est calé
crasseuse tout le monde le dit à tout le
monde le dit et que bon si la france
doit tenir ce qu'est paribas s'est pas
en chanteur mais maintenant je me
permettrais pas de dire que qui que ce
soit n'est pas républicain n'est pas
démocrate parce que personne n'a le
brevet qui permet de dire de telles
choses je crois qu'il faut qu'on se
respecte dans une république et madame
hidalgo en tenant ces propos se montre
très irrespectueuse des règles de la
relation du débat républicain voilà bons
mots faciles à faire jean-loup vrai coup
je voudrais qu'on regarde ce sondage à
présent 1 22% pour marine le pen qui
serait au second tour je le rappelle
face à emmanuel macron contre 8% pour
l'instant pour anne hidalgo alors
évidemment ce ne sont que des sondages
on a vu ce que ça a donné pour les
régionales les sondages étaient étaient
faux néanmoins la mairie de paris pour
talent être un tremplin pour anne
hidalgo comme ça a été le cas par
exemple pour pour jacques chirac
et la science sont différents pour
revenir à ce que disent et monsieur
sue collard moi j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour lui je crois qu'il faut qu'il ait
beaucoup de respect aussi pour le
président de paris ont reconduit anne
hidalgo donc c'est que apparemment d'un
point de vue démocratique que la
politique à l'amener à paris convient
aux paris convenait au parisien et je
crois que effectivement la meilleure des
politiques c'est déjà de respecter les
choix de des électeurs
on en début de campagne je crois que il
faut ces sondages ça veut pas dire grand
chose on a vu toutes les surprises qui a
pu y avoir on a vu toutes les erreurs
aussi qu'il peut y avoir sur les
sondages au niveau des régionales
non mais je sais qu'un d'eux j'ai encore
beaucoup d'espoir je suis persuadé que
je crois que notre la france a besoin
déjà d'apaisement je pense que si une
personne qui est capable
d'apaiser un petit peu toutes ces
tensions qu'on a en france qui sont moi
que je trouve insupportable je sais que
tu y vas ces attaques comme vous venez
ferme ce qu'au large tout ça pour ça le
fossat méprisant de gelson
jeu l'attaqué personnes et pourquoi
parler de pourquoi de dire que je suis
méprisant je me permettrais pas de dire
que vous êtes la prison parce que
jamais présent ils font donc il faut
avoir du respect pour toi on va attendre
un petit peu comment heureux vous disent
les sondages pensent que voilà on aura
des surprises on va regarder un peu plus
en détail parmi les mesures phares de
marine le pen la nationalisation des
autoroutes et la privatisation de l'eau
d'autres l'audiovisuel culé je vais y
arriver pour sauvegarder vos pouvoir
d'achat des français gilbert collard qu
un commentaire moi je considère que la
privatisation est une et une est une
évidence un bon on
wii wii 2
parce que l'audiovisuel public est entre
et il ne répond pas à la demande
des auditeurs ou des téléspectateurs qui
qui sont qui sont soumis à une audio
visuel très et trop orienté
politiquement et puis mise à part la
communication internationale où il faut
qu'on soit présent bien évidemment je
considère que c'est aussi de là une
forme de liberté d'expression
700 euros par an voilà déjà coûté très
cher et très souvent les auditeurs et
les téléspectateurs qui se tapent du
routier ou lui du madame e léa salamé
n'ont pas forcément envie d'avoir de
l'audiovisuel de gauche bon alors donc
il faut qu'il y ait des faut qu'il y ait
une espèce de pluralisme et puis et puis
c'est la liberté quoi là c'est fini
l'époque pétainiste de la télé d'état ou
de la ou de la radio d'état je crois que
tout le monde de ce point de vue là
devraient être d'accord bon et radio
d'état les télévisions d'état
cc c'est démodé c'est plus dans l'ère de
la liberté donc c'est vrai que ce serait
une bonne chose on est un pluralisme
privatifs des opinions des idées
qu'il faut en finir avec
trois équilibre dans les
voilà qu'on ne soit pas dans des
logiques trop mercantile et qu'on puisse
donner une tpe qu'ils soient eux qui se
propose un panel de
l'information avoir d information
plurielle je pense qu'on a on a besoin
d'une culture plurielle ton est un peu
toutes les tendances qui soit y soient
représentés
je crois tout l'audiovisuel public c'est
une forme d' équilibre dans dans la
formation d'une façon générale pourront
quant aux autoroutes par contre je suis
complètement d'accord pour que l swan
nationaliser parce que ça coûte aussi
très cher aux français en impro quelque
part multipliée par dole et les salaires
des enseignants et revaloriser les
métiers
invisible comme les soignants ou les
caissières c'est des mesures défendues
par anne hidalgo ce sont les bonnes
mesures selon vous gilbert collard et
qui va payer ces résultats tout vous
savez quand on fait le geek c'est qu'une
c'est d'une banalité
désespérante que de le dire mais quand
on quand on voit le travail que fait une
infirmière ou un infirmier un
aide-soignant taux ou une aide soignante
quand on voit la masse humaine de
dévouement et les salaires correspondent
c'est une autre c'est non on fait rien
comparé à d mais quand une mesure est
bonne elle est bonne moi je veux dire
une chose une bonne mesure de gauche
c'est une bonne mesure de france bon une
bonne mesure de droite c'est une bonne
mesure de france 3 qu'il faudrait qu'on
arrive quand même un jour ou l'autre un
art être capable de le dire qu'on s'est
dit prêt il n'est pas tolérable que que
les enseignants que les soignants qui
sont faits qui sont au coeur de la prise
en charge de nos vies de nos formations
de nos souffrances soient ainsi payer
alors convoi d'aidé les stars de la
télévision ou des stars du football
toucher des salaires mirobolants ça
m'insupporte honnête dans un
jean louis bricout revaloriser x dont
les salaires d'abord première question
qui va payer et je rebondis sur les
taxes de la maire de paris qui veut
taxer les automobilistes s'en va c'est
pas non plus les gens les plus aisés
alors est-ce qu'une cohérence avec cette
politique en faveur des invisibles et en
même temps une politique de taxation à
paris oui
les roadies commission quelque part
évidemment quand on parle d'une dépense
il faut à borghetto obligatoirement
parler de de recettes à et des recettes
c'est souvent la peau donc vous être
regardant les ce qu'on peut avancer mais
évidemment il ya un vrai sujet sur le
niveau de salaire sont à revalorisation
de certains métiers s'était rappelée
pour les enseignants qui sont deux fois
mafia payer effectivement que kane
enseignants allemands par exemple c'est
vrai pour les infirmières scolaires a
complètement raison c'est vrai pour les
auxiliaires de vie par exemple qui ont
quand même des conditions de vie et des
métiers extrêmement difficile et des
ponts tout le monde a besoin je crois
qu'on a on a tous besoin à un moment tu
ne sers de vie à un moment de sa vie
donc un vrai sujet effectivement sur
sur le niveau salaires sur
l'augmentation des revenus ou parle donc
pas d'augmentation du smic par exemple
s'il pour les ouvriers ceux qui
travaillent qui s'est tôt le matin comme
on a l'habitude de dire est que voilà et
qui ont du mal à finir les fins de mois
et des mois qui suit dans la ruralité
sur des terres industrielles agricoles
il ya vraiment un vrai sujet sur les
revenus attend il faut faut travailler
sur le sujet pour voir comment on crée
pas des déséquilibres évidemment
budgétaire et il ya moyen d'aller
chercher des nouvelles recettes 1 sur l'
isf par exemple je vous prendre un
exemple si on rétablissait likès fc 3 2
milliards de recettes en plus dans le
budget de l'état et si on redistribue
vers les retraités les retraités pauvres
c'est 1000 euros pour 3,2 pour 320
millions d'euros traités vous vous
rendez compte ce que ça peut représenter
quoi donc évidemment il ya des solutions
pour répondre à un vrai problème qui est
celui de celui des revenus qui sont ils
sont trop bas des salaires sont trop bas
pour certains métiers qui ont très dur
gilbert collard très quoi un commentaire
à ce rétablissement de dolly sf nous
reste quelques secondes - à titre
personnel je suis pour le rétablissement
je suis absolument hostile à la taxation
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui
qui favorise finalement le moulin la
finança visible la finance immatériel
celle du raid mais je m'accroche pas
trop hein ccc c'est un pur produit
fantomatique mais réelle de la finance
invisible cette finance qui maîtrise le
monde qu'on retrouve dans les gaffes à
qu'on retrouve dans les sociétés
offshore on retrouve dans le cadre 40
qu'on retrouve et cliquetis goût qui
gouvernent jamais marx dans ses pires
cauchemars n'aurait pu imaginer que le
capital un jour concentré devint aussi
puissant
jamais on n'aurait pu imaginer qu'on
soit soumis à ce point à la banque à
l'assurance à l'immatérialité de
l'argent qui vraiment nous domestique
et c'est le fait de banquiers d'argent
d'affaires de tout un monde qui connaît
la technique et on est soumis
complètement avec la complicité
charnelle réel
dégueulasse de l'union européenne qui
prête la manne ce sera le mot de la fin
merci gilbert collard et merci à vous
jean louis bricout d'avoir participé ce
matin à ce débat sur arte france